let's get off of these questions of
natural law and souls and everything get
on to the real battle the war on
Christmas here is a glimpse right now
from the battlefield just outside our
window no they got him they got him they
got Santa Santa down I got to put on my
helmet for this this is it still lit up
yeah it is okay alright ready to go I
don't have my candy cane pipe anymore
Matt I read it I usually I love your
writing I love reading your pieces you
wrote a piece a couple days ago that I
almost threw my computer at the window I
was so horrified I wanted to bring you
up on charges marshal charges for
evacuating your post in the war on
Christmas you don't think it's a real
thing
you don't think conservatives should be
worried about it no not at all I think
it's it's if you think it's ridiculous I
well that is not mean that's not that's
practically yeah my Christmas tree bow
tie I I think it's even dumber than the
standing the NFL think I'll be honest
with you I there there there are two
aspects to it the question is is it is
it an important issue like is there
something we should worry about and the
other question is should we even is it
even is it helping Christmas in other
words when we try to essentially force
people to say Merry Christmas and to
decorate their department stores with
with mistletoes and plastic reindeer and
everything and so on that second I think
I move right to that second question I
would say that it's it's I don't think
that we we help Christmas in other words
if you have what would we consider an
act of war on Christmas if like for
instance if Macy's were to say we're
banning Christmas decorations you're not
allowed to say Merry Christmas right
then that's that's the war on Christmas
isn't it's the latter though because it
they still have the decorations the
decorations are up everywhere it's not
like we forced them to people put them
up because if they put them up earlier
and earlier actually because they want
to get people to buy more presents and
these sort of things the the act of the
war on Christmas and why I think it's so
insidious is it's all about language
it's just a front in this politically
correct
euphemistic battle so what they do is
they have all the
the reindeer even they have the little
Christmas snowflakes or whatever but
they won't they won't call it Christmas
they'll say it's for the holidays they
use this euphemism holidays even though
there's only one major holiday in
December so how let me ask you how is
the sacredness of Christmas preserved by
having the cashier JCPenney just have
this wrote greeting of Merry Christmas
as opposed to saying happy holidays
which by the way as you know holidays
means holy day so they're still
acknowledging but they say holidays but
if there's only one there's only one
major holiday in December what's the
other holiday Hanukkah is a relatively
minor Jewish holiday
compared to other Jewish holidays it
only became a busy day of Saint Nicholas
the this is actually another point on
this so you do make a great point
obviously Christmas is commercialized a
lot of people there the Christmas and
Easter Christians they go to church
twice a year maybe usually once a year
and they don't go any other day and
that's a problem I totally grant that
that's a problem but it isn't hypocrisy
the tribute the device pays to virtue is
it is that situation really made better
by indulging this bizarre campaign to
replace Christmas the obviously the
central holiday of Christmas time with
this weird euphemism holidays where we
pretend that Hanukkah is a major holiday
even within the Jewish religion and the
Kwanzaa is anything but a socialist
contrivance it seems to me you know
Santa we have Santa Claus up what does
Santa Claus have to do with the birth
birth of Christ not terribly much except
that this folk tradition that we have
the merging of the of Christianity with
these various folk traditions does speak
a little bit to it we have Saint
Nicholas so we have st. Nicholas is
known for two things
giving up presents to people and
punching heretics in the face and we
incorporate the former into our
Christmas traditions that doesn't seem
like such a bad thing to me yeah I would
love to incorporate the latter to it
right the Walsh household if I started
doing that at Macy's
but I I guess the here's here's the way
I look at it if a department store a
company or whatever says don't say Merry
Christmas a Happy Holidays their logic
partly is well we can't really wish
because Christmas means Christ mass as
you know it's it's a very religious
phrase and it's it's it's intensely
religious so the the the logic of these
corporations is well if we say that then
we're essentially endorsing that
religion we're promoting it and and so
they say well we're a secular company
we're not interested in promoting a
religion so we're just going to back off
and not and not say anything or just use
this generalized phrase and my point is
in that decision they're actually
showing more respect even if not
intentionally but they're showing more
respect for the religious nature of
Christmas then are a lot of Christians
who only care about Christianity when
it's Christmas time but then shouldn't
they not use the word holy day shouldn't
they not use the phrase holidays that
they're saying we don't want to take a
religious stand because I think they're
not using it for that reason I think
they're not doing it because there's a
left-wing euphemistic struggle that
infects all of our politically correct
language christmas is just one little
aspect of that but by that logic if
there is only one major holiday that is
celebrated in december shouldn't they
just not acknowledge anything if they're
going to acknowledge that there is
something there is a holiday that must
not be named because we're respecting
the religious nature of of this country
and of the people who celebrate
christmas then they should take down the
ornaments right they should take down
the snowflakes and the trees and the
reindeer so my so my I guess I would I
guess my problem with the war on
Christmas is that they're not going far
enough take take the tech to take it all
down I don't it's because I don't need
this this this the way that Christmas is
so ubiquitous it's only drained at of
its significance I think it would be
great we live in a part of the point I
made in that piece we live in a godless
satanic culture we should have to face
that fact even around Christmas I know
we want to run from that and we want to
pretend we're driving down the street we
see the Christmas lights everywhere was
it well look at all these Christians are
so great and meanwhile you know those
people the Christmas lights are in their
house you know they're looking at porn
there whatever beating their kids
whatever they're doing so what you want
to do you want to take down the reindeer
and you want to replace them with little
devils and little like balances it's I
think it would be good if we got to a
point in our culture where only the
people who are authentically really
devoutly observantly Christian even
acknowledge or celebrate Christmas
because they're the only ones who should
be they're the only ones it it's it's
this is not a holiday for everyone to
enjoy the spirit of Christmas is giving
to people it's not what it is we're
celebrating the birth of Christ because
he came to this earth to redeem mankind
that's why we're celebrating him and so
it's the people who actually care about
Christianity who have a right to our
celebration I don't like how our culture
comes in and takes all of the Christmas
all the Christian celebrations and
givers gets rid of all the religious
significance and they just keep that
they keep the celebrations for
themselves to do with Mardi Gras they do
it sort of with you know they do I
certainly do it Mardi Gras yeah they do
with Saint Patrick's Day
it's you know these are ours we we
earned those holidays in a sense
culturally appropriating from us they
already did away on this point though
the the Incarnation does draw all of the
nations in the world into Christ even
though you know we see those three wise
men come from the land of the sunrise
they weren't Jews they lived at a time
when there was there were prophecies
floating around that the ruler of the
world would come from Judah but even in
that incarnate in the first year of
incarnation you see a journey of the
world who might be kind of kooky and
their religious views are a little out
there or not quite there might be Magi
from which we get magician but they were
drawn a little closer to Christ it
seemed I'm looking at it a little more
glass-half-full if we can get them to
like Santa Claus this happened to Andrew
Clavin he really liked Christmas as a
boy even though he came from a basically
secular Jewish household and years later
that played some role in his conversion
to Christ you know what in a way that
didn't involve Christmas cookies and you
know little decorations on the tree
because I think in where I disagree with
you Matt is what you're talking about is
a society that completely totally takes
away their decorations and it's gone and
it's everything that's not a society
that takes away their decorations and
we're gonna let the Christians do their
thing that's a society like the Soviet
Union they don't just take the
decorations down they ensure that nobody
puts any decorations up so we're in a
post-christian society right now but we
are not yet fully in an anti-christian
society yet and so long as that shell of
a Christian society remains we have to
protect that shell so we can fill it up
with something Christian because that
natural law of being around the beauty
of the decorations of Christmas and
hearing people say Merry Christmas and
Santa Claus
like he said about Andrew Clavin could
play a role in somebody's conversion
later on I know how to do it I know how
to make all of this work and to unite
all of these various armies some who
want more Santa Claus and some who want
the war to go further and you know have
the devil's go up we can we have to add
this important component of punching
heretics to our Christmas traditions yes
Saint Nicholas as Santa Claus himself
would have wanted
fala Lala la lalalala